أحمر الشعر لا يمكنها أن تكون جيدة في ذلك
رهيب لجميع المعنيين.
من الصعب تخمين ما يبدو عليه الأمر
لا ينبغي أن يصاب السكان العاديون في أوكرانيا بالذعر
كيف تعتقد أنه إذا كان يهدد
شعبنا بحاجة لحمايتنا
لذلك يتم تطبيق مبدأ الضربة
تسير وفقًا للخطة أعتقد أنها صحيحة
الحل لجيل الشباب
بشكل عام حالة حرجة بسبب
الآن قم بتغيير الأجيال بشكل جيد
الخطة السوفيتية لشاب وهذا
على العكس من ذلك ، فإنه يخلق المزيد من المشاكل
فقط لجيل الشباب لأنه
كل ذلك سيقع في النهاية على عاتقنا
أكتاف ما هو موجود الآن مع هؤلاء
العقوبات التي هي الآن لنا مع هذا
التدخل في أوكرانيا لأشعل النار
على أي حال ، سيتعين على جميع البلدان
الركبتين المقبلتين لذلك فهي ذات شقين
من جانب واحد قبل طلباتها
أريد أن أساعد من أنا الآن ولكن أوه
يصبح المستقبل ضعيفًا بطريقة ما